alors messieurs reste vos enfants j'ai
des valeurs
c'est du vin de la nes la dernière
récolte des boues il assez typé gamme et
un c'est le millésime 72 et les biens
que l'horreur oui et il doit avoir des
défauts quand même jour la caunette un
petit peu un avis ce sérieux parce qu on
est toujours inquiet nous l'aimions moi
je ne trouve à peu un peu ce à quoi les
jeunes arrivent à se faire il sera bon
ils seront dans quelques mois quoi où et
c'est sûr c'est un peu le choléra l'an
dernier ça nous sommes ici au coeur du
blaisois région glavine et de traditions
anciennes
c'est le vignoble des châteaux la
présence de la cour des rois de france
qui a joué un rôle important et c'est
surtout aux 15e et 16e siècles qu'ils se
développent actuellement ce vignoble est
en pleine mutation dans ses structures
dans sa superficie qui a baissé de façon
alarmante mais qui se stabilise
maintenant dans son encépagement dont la
gamme sont restreints très nettement
dans le but de créer un kit de 20 plus
personnalisé en s'imposant des
disciplines de production et de
commercialisation des vignerons de ses
poteaux du blésois ont fortement
contribué au redressement viticoles de
la région
y at-il dans cette région de nouveaux
modes de conduite de la vigne
oui vous êtes ici dans une vie où l'on
appelle large et haute parce que les
viticulteurs ont été amenés pour les
questions économiques a diminué densité
de plantation et à rehausser les souches
aussi pour des questions de mandeure et
quels sont les avantages de ces 8 août
eh bien ça permet d'éviter certaines
gelés d'une part parce qu'on aille plus
loin du sol et d'autre part par
l'enherbement que vous constatez sur le
sol se permet de pouvoir passer par
n'importe quel temps donc de pouvoir
être plus à même de traiter la vigne et
de préserver les raisins jusqu'à la
récolte et désavantages aussi pour les
bandes hors jeu oui parce que les
vendangeurs ont moins mal aux reins
on ne peut pas les amener dans une ville
basse après les avoir faits vendangé
dans une vigne haut ils sont très rares
dans notre région et sont en
développement actuellement depuis une
dizaine d'années quelles sont les
qualités particulières de ce terroir
je viens ici nous sommes sur des
terrains argilo calcaire très perméable
propice à la vigne et il ya même
certaines zones très caillouteuses qui
sont très bonnes pour le fruité de nos
vins et quels cépages mais vous êtes ici
devant dugas mais ne s'est pas du
beaujolais mais le fleuron de la région
c'est quand même le sauvignon
ici ce sont des pays des noms qui
sonnent clé reggae mont-près-chambord
sellette chitenay cour cheverny petit
vignoble sans doute comment d'autres
régions berry orléanais vallée du cher
où des viticulteurs ce groupe pour
travailler dans le sens de la qualité on
peut dire que pour vous définir que vous
êtes un artisan vino qu'en pensez vous
ce terme vous plaît en un sens oui on a
surtout à coeur de notre profession et
puis on essaie surtout de faire du bon
vin
qu'est ce que c'est pour vous du bon vin
comment peut-on faire du groupe va
bientôt faire du bon vin et si on se
place dans la vinification et les
conditions essentielles sont déjà la
propreté est un bon vigneron c'est
surtout d'un gars qui fait beaucoup de
lessive
parce que il faut pas hésiter c'est à
dire il faut nettoyer les fûts vous
devriez les fûts et puis d'abord en
premier lieu la pour le pressoir l'écu
et puis j'ai vu parce qu'on sert encore
tout de même des flux oui tout ça
demande beaucoup de travail on à bras de
bons vins sans travail
non mais il faut aussi un beau vignoble
mais c'est d'abord la condition première
mais il faut d'abord avoir un bon dans
ces pages on est seul on doit ce blanc
cépage mans depuis les jeunes quinzaine
d'années grâce à la chambre
d'agriculture
oui tous ces techniciens le disposition
et c'est très content 73 s'annonce bien
c'est une très belle récolte
vous êtes un vigneron optimiste relevant
les vignerons peuvent 72 non et c'est
une très belle récolte je vais pas dire
que ce sera un millésime peut être à
tout casser mais ce sera un très bon
les vignes sont merveilleux des raisins
sont très sains vous parle beaucoup des
vins en ce moment et vous faites un 20e
net
qu'entendez vous par 20 net et bien
c'est surtout un vin qui sortent du
raisin c'est à dire c'est du jus de
raisin
je ne veux pas m'étendre là dessus mais
voyez-vous nos vins sont travailler dans
des conditions naturelles qui sont
contrôlés tout de même par un
laboratoire
alors il suffit de surveiller au départ
bien aux fermentations c'est très
important
alors il faut produits de choc de
l'emballement de la fermentation pour la
chaleur il faut pour les
refroidissements trop brutaux tout ça
c'est une histoire d'observation alors
c'est un petit peu le nez du vigneron
des fois aussi qui fait l affaire
alors on appelle ça un vin le net c'est
peut-être le grand beau conte emploi
mais il a sa raison d'être parce que
c'est absolument le vin tel qu'on en a
récolté
les vendeurs 73 termine sauvignon
vianney pineau ample vin est tiré il
faut le boire
mais la qualité pq
récompenser nos efforts puisque dans
cette région qui est dans cette région
du blaisois on vient d'obtenir
maintenant vdqs vin délimité de qualité
supérieure qui vient d'être officialisé
par texte du 12 août dernier et c'est
maintenant l'appellation vdqs cheverny
et qui englobe toute la région de se
blesser voire des photos du blaisois
anciennement